Academy Award nominated actress Margot
Robbie has made a name for herself by
portraying cultural female icons whether
it's actress Sharon Tate controversial
figure skater Tonya Harding Queen
Elizabeth or everyone's childhood BFF
Barbie the woman is nothing if not
versatile so today we step into the
shoes of one of Hollywood's hottest
stars and attempt to eat like Margot
Robbie for a day hey one I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'll be attempting to eat like
oscar-nominated actress Margot Robbie
but obviously not quite because my needs
are ultimately unique so I'm going to be
using her alleged meals as a template
for teaching gems nutrition and
inspiring what I decide to make for
myself that works for me and my body
also a reminder that this diet was
compiled from primary and secondary
sources so I really cannot speak to its
legitimacy or accuracy and a reminder
that this is just what I ate on a random
day and it's not meant to be copied or
recommended as to how you should eat so
always speak to registered dietitian
about your unique needs and if you guys
are new here hit that subscribe button
and follow me on Instagram and Tick Tock
at Abby's kitchen alright Abby I'm
hungry let's eat this is a really good
one I mean I feel like Margot is so
talented so beautiful so versatile so
she's obviously had to undergo a bunch
of different physical Transformations
for different roles and at different
points in her career that's meant she's
had to stick to a pretty strict diet and
according to Emirates woman magazine
Margot has described herself as being
pretty extreme in her diet stating that
she does not do good at moderation she's
literally said that she loves beers and
fries and burgers but if she has to get
into a bikini for a roll she'll eat
carrot sticks for three days Hold Up
Wait A Minute yikes not exactly how I
like to roll yoyoing from one diet
extreme to another is typically not
great for our gut microbiome our mood
digestion energy levels or our
relationship with food it just doesn't
generally feel very good and apparently
margot's movie prep diet typically will
cut out chocolate fast food sugary
drinks and saturated fats I the first
three but Abby what's the deal on
snapbacks well it's complicated but in
the simplest terms possible we used to
think that saturated fats were the cause
of heart disease but more recent Studies
have actually found that there was not
enough evidence to conclude that
saturated fats increase the risk but
that replacing saturated fats with
polyunsaturated fats or high fiber
carbohydrates help to reduce the risk
that said there's nothing particularly
unique about saturated fats when it
comes to weight loss or weight gain I
mean all fats are high in calories and
without a calorie deficit you don't lose
weight so I think it's useful to make
smart use of saturated fats I don't
think that you need to completely cut
them out all right Abby that was a lot
for 9am tell me there's some caffeine in
my near future oh I'm a massive loser
and I carry tea bags around with me
because I like a very particular brand
of tea that is some serious tea
commitment right there now I had to
Google this brand that she uses Dilma
and while I didn't really specify
because I know they have like a bunch of
different varietals I'm pretty sure it's
like a classic black tea so I've got one
of those right there I'm usually a
coffee girl but you know I can do a cup
of tea caffeine is caffeine right
actually Abby ah yes the great debate
coffee versus tea let's break down some
key benefits it's and how they compare
first up cognitive performance so
resource suggests that low to moderate
doses of caffeine can help to improve
attention span vigilance alertness and
reaction time a typical cup of coffee
has about 96 milligrams of caffeine
while a cup of black tea has about half
that amount but there is such a thing as
too much of a good thing and while one
city comparing black tea and black
coffee found similar effects on
alertness and cognitive performance the
tea had a lower risk of disrupting sleep
so I'm going to give that one to our
friend T second is antioxidant content
both tea and coffee are rich in
antioxidants called polyphenols which
help to reduce the risk of chronic
disease but while coffee has twice the
amount of antioxidants as green or black
tea about 200 milligrams for coffee
versus 115 milligrams for green tea and
96 milligrams for black both tea and
coffee are associated with heart health
and a reduced risk of cardiovascular
disease so I would say that one's a draw
when it comes to cancer only coffee but
not tea has been shown to help reduce
the risk and then there's the risk of
diabetes so coffee has pretty strong
evidence in its favor suggesting that it
may help to reduce the risk of diabetes
and while some research suggests the
same for tea other studies haven't found
such a clear Association finally let's
talk stress and mental health in this
case it kind of depends what your goal
is so coffee is higher in caffeine which
can increase cortisol which helps to
lift your mood while tea is rich in
l-theanine which has a more calming
effect so where does this leave us
honestly who cares both are
nutritious in moderation so drink your
ritualistic Brew how you like it and
don't let anyone tell you to stop cheers
Abby nothing like a hot cup of tea out
of a big ass mug all right let's talk
breakfast so Margot told Women's Health
UK that her typical morning breakfast
routine consists of porridge along
within a Community boosting smoothie
well I mean aside from the questionable
recipe description this
this actually sound like
sound like Abby can you go over why this
whole idea of immunity boosting is kind
of bunk you got it girl I've said it
here before and I'll say it again until
I'm blue in the face there is nothing we
can do to boost our immune system in
fact we wouldn't actually want to boost
or enhance our immune system anyway as
an overactive immune system might
actually attack the body's systems as is
the case with autoimmune disorders
something to think about that now
supporting your immune system on the
other hand means engaging in lifestyle
behaviors to help ensure that your
immune system is functioning optimally
so for example we know that things like
getting quality sleep managing stress
and regular physical activity plus
prioritizing probiotics and antioxidant
rich foods all can help to support a
healthy immune system so a smoothie that
is packed with colorful fruits and veg
definitely fits the bill berries banana
Greek yogurt kale peanut butter
hemp hearts soy milk
and little honey
now let's make some oatmeal all right
let's mix together some oats
a little more
and some almond milk
I never measure I just kind of let it
cook until it's out of consistency I
like pinch of salt
cinnamon
and a handful of hand parts
letter simmer five minutes later so my
little hack is I always add a really
ripe banana in for all y'all banana
haters you can leave this out and just
throw in whatever kind of Honey or maple
syrup or fruit that you like but I find
that it adds a really nice consistency
and texture and adds a ton of natural
sweetness that's going in
I'm gonna add a little scoop of peanut
butter inside and then I'll do a little
bit more on top
and some protein powder
off stir everything in and this is where
I like make a call as to how much more
liquid I need I don't like my oats too
thick
so I'm going to add a little bit more
there we go
let's plate her up look at that it looks
so good every single day my kid wakes up
and the first thing he says to me is not
hi Mama or good morning or I love you
it's me oatmeal meat oatmeal is
literally what he says every effing day
and if I don't present him with oatmeal
it's meltdown City so
a little bit of peanut butter
right on top because I like to swirl I
like to swirl now my mouth is stuck
together
a little extra hemp
and some berries got a little
raspberries some blueberries
this one's not good
baby strawberry a little grape action
this is the consistency of perfect
oatmeal it's got a little jiggle not too
stiff not too loose
perfect and speaking of perfect nobody
needs an immune boosting smoothie when
you got this going on we have tons of
immune supporting antioxidants in all
the berries that we used plus the kale
and the oats and the nut butter and the
Honey like all of these ingredients will
help to support a healthy immune system
not to mention we also have lots of
protein in the protein powder and the
Hem parts and the Greek yogurt fiber in
all of our fruits and veg and our oats
and healthy fats in the hemp and the nut
Butters this is a super generous portion
but the good news is that both of these
things keep really really well so I can
always enjoy some of it tomorrow
um
all right speaking of supporting
immunity it's time for a little movement
so according to Women's Health UK
magazine margot's workout routine will
typically fluctuate depending on the
role that she's training for so for
example she was doing like a lot of
boxing and fight training for Suicide
Squad and lots of skating and core
exercises for I Tonya when she's not
preparing for a role she's all about
incorporating different kind of fun
activities that she enjoys so she plays
tennis with her friends she does dance
classes she surfs she does Pilates we
love the variety but obviously it's the
dead of winter and I don't have access
to a tennis court or a surfboard but we
can't always put on a little YouTube
Pilates and get some movement in toffee
I need my emotional support let's move
all right let's go work out
[Music]
[Applause]
so it is officially time for lunch and
according to Emirates woman magazine
Margot Ops for a salad with lemon
chicken for lunch no clue what that
entails as there is no recipe beyond
that description we're going to
improvise with what I have on hand and
try to make this as fast as possible
let's make lunch
all right I got some bagged salad
leftover chicken
oh let's do you
uh
maybe I'll throw some of that in there
and oh
we need lemon
if it's a lemon salad we need a lemon
this is how I like to make lunch because
has time to like make an entire
multi-course meal from scratch in the
middle of the day not me
[Music]
so
I've got some leftover wild rice here
with sweet potato and apple and roasted
broccoli from dinner I got this bag
salad
on sale
throw some greens in
nice combo
I think
tossita
I love grapes in a salad it's just like
oh just adds a juicy hit of sweetness if
I can get the grape to like work into
the flavor profile I'm adding it in
Chef's gonna work really nicely here
a little crumble
let's get fancy and caramelize up some
walnuts
some little Walnut pieces
and some maple syrup
oh
walnuts and Maple
Just Hits different we need lemon so
let's make a lemon vinaigrette
AKA a citronette you can bust that out
at your next dinner party
lemon juice let's remove the seeds
nobody needs that
nobody needs to grow lemon tree in their
gut
a little bit of Dijon
some olive oil
and
the last of my maple syrup
gotta get some protein in here so I've
got some leftover chicken breast
so yummy
love the little crunch of whole grain
mustard
I'm excited about that all right super
quickie salad here and literally used up
all of the leftovers in my fridge which
we love and looks unbelievable love
these kind of makeshift salads they just
work themselves out so nicely there's
just so much in here I don't even know
where to start but we got lots of five
Rich carbs in our wild rice and sweet
potatoes and apples and grapes so good
plus some extra fiber and micronutrients
in all of our greens and veg we got
healthy fats in the olive oil dressing
and in the walnuts plus we've got our
protein in the leftover chicken I didn't
even know where to start but
how am I going to get a perfect bite
well we gotta get the ghost cheese
that's a must gotta get a grape gotta
get the Walnut
and maybe a little sweet potato too
yum
keep it a classy here folks
one bite at a time
got some work done picked up the kids
now it's time for dinner and the good
news is we got a few options here to
work with so according to a few
different sources Margot loves fish
specifically tuna steak with a side of
sweet potatoes and roasted veg otherwise
she loves a classic burger and fries
though this does kind of break her dye
rules on the kind of no fast food and no
saturated fat front I don't usually buy
tuna steaks because they are so high in
mercury and I try to make meals that the
whole family can enjoy including my kids
but I figured we could do like a really
easy fish burger that the whole family
can enjoy okay so while I get prepping
on that Abby can you give us the rundown
on Mercury considerations when buying
fish sure thing so I first want to note
that an occasional tuna steak is really
not a big deal for healthy adults but if
tuna is a staple for you it may be
worthwhile choosing lower Mercury
options more often now while it depends
on variety tuna steaks tend to be about
3 to six times higher in Mercury
compared to light canned tuna so yeah
that is
quite a jump now to put this
up for you even if you were to choose
the lowest Mercury option like Yellowfin
even a three ounce serving would exceed
the maximum safe dose established by the
EPA on the higher end just one three
ounce serving of big eye tuna would
exceed the max weekly safe dose now this
is not to say that you shouldn't live
your best life and enjoy tuna steak if
this is something that is enjoyable and
pleasurable for you but like I said we
just want to be mindful of frequency of
consumption and choosing lower Mercury
fish options whenever we can especially
if our kiddos are enjoying these meals
as well all right we got some
cauliflower I'm gonna roast up
a little olive oil
and salt and pepper
and you know what
let's get a little spice action I'm
obsessed with zatar if you know you know
and because everyone knows that crinkle
cut fries are legit the best kind of
fries and I cannot compete with McCain
Frozen we're going with the good stuff
[Applause]
this is your daily reminder that if
convenience foods help you get a
balanced meal on the table they are a
great tool in the toolbox
let's pop these in the oven and we'll
work on our burgers and I just picked
these up at my local fishmonger because
today as you can see we're going the
easy route with the cooking here we are
going Barbie vibes
[Music]
oh yeah
all right
Cooks so good sweet potato fries
cauliflower
enough farts for one meal let's build a
fish burger we got some avocado
I found some tartar sauce in the fridge
left over from fish and chip night
amazing
can't have a fish burger with a little
tartar got some jalapenos
little spice and tomatoes
and our little cupla
little fish burger
and a squish
oh hello I am so excited about this meal
and it really was so easy to pull off
mainly because I bought the fish Burgers
already made we got lots of fiber rich
carbs in our sweet potatoes plus some
extra fiber in our cauliflower here
heart healthy omega-3 fats and protein
in the fish burger and we got the
classic fast food Vibes with the crinkle
cut fries
you cannot have sweet potato fries any
other way what is going to be the least
messy bite
it was so good
it is officially my favorite time of day
dessert all right talk sweet to me baby
okay so according to a bunch of sources
Margo once said that chocolate waffles
and Fries were some of her favorite food
groups and she's also a big fan of ice
cream what's your advice
ice cream it is very much okay to enjoy
food just how it is and sometimes I feel
like ice cream is perfection all on its
own
kind of
where's my elbow guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah sure
I'm happy
a really fun day I mean we got to have a
lot of really great easy fast
convenience meals and I also feel like I
got a lot of variety and balance I gotta
have some ice cream I got some sweet
potato fries I got some burgs in there
but I also had a really nourishing salad
smoothie and oatmeal Bowl to boot just
like margot's career it felt like a
really well-rounded day so on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with what or who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]